die grausame und abscheuliche invasion
russlands in der ukraine war für die
meisten von uns wie für die überwiegende
mehrheit der analysten experten und
journalisten sowohl im militärbereich
als auch in der internationalen politik
eine ziemliche überraschung eine groß
angelegte invasion mit mehreren fronten
den beschuss von städten und der
besetzung der ganzen ukraine schien mit
der vor ihrem stadt zusammengezogen
russischen truppenstärke kein
realisierbare szenario zu sein der
brachiale einmarsch der russischen
truppen in die ukraine hat die alte
weltordnung und die gewissheiten an die
so vielen menschen als regierungen lange
geglaubt haben portal über den haufen
geworfen
auch dem letzten hinter hitler wurde nun
klar dass wladimir putin ein
gefährlicher psychopath ist dessen
stärkste was wir schon immer
unberechenbarkeit war wohlgemerkt seine
eigene unberechenbarkeit nur sie
beherrscht er denn er ist wahrlich kein
meister der unberechenbarkeit an sich er
hat weder mit der großen
widerstandskraft der ukraine gerechnet
noch mit der harten reaktion des westens
welche diesmal weit über das übliche maß
hinaus denn der wirtschaftskrise ich
meine die ökonomische spezialoperation
zur der ratifizierung der weltwirtschaft
wird russland in die steinzeit zurück
befördern und in die absolute
abhängigkeit von china treiben sein land
zur aggressoren nation paar extras zu
machen zu einem pari am schuldenstaat
war eine der absurdesten entscheidungen
der weltgeschichte der krieg in der
ukraine hat so etwas wie eine zeitreise
ausgelöst plötzlich scheint der kalte
krieg zurückgekehrt zu sein die
unverblümte wahrheit lautet also
russland mag ein verarmtes isoliertes
und korruptes land sein aber es ist
immer noch eine der größten atommächte
27 februar
2022 putin versetzt nuklearer
abschreckungskräfte in höchste
alarmbereitschaft inmitten der sich
verschärfenden spannungen um die ukraine
qualitativ sprechen wir von nichts
geringerem als der größten atommacht der
erde und deshalb müssen wir in diesem
video unbedingt ein paar drängende
fragen beantworten zu welch
unberechenbaren und des
selbstzerstörerischen taten ist putin
noch fähig ist er die erlösung des fermi
paradoxon lautet der name des großen
filters unserer zivilisation schlicht
und einfach putin der letzte
sind wir so jämmerlich dass wir es noch
nicht einmal schaffen eines super
intelligenz oder nano box zu erschaffen
welche die menschheit auslöschen werden
wie hoch ist das risiko eines
apokalyptischen atomkriegs wie würde
diese ausgelöst was genau umfasst
eigentlich die doktrin der nuklearen
abschreckung und welche rolle spielt sie
in moskaus plänen welche szenarien plant
russland für den einsatz von atomwaffen
können sie jemals auf ukrainischen
schlachtfeldern eingesetzt werden tja
alles sehr spannende und im wahrsten
wortsinne weltbewegende fragen die wir
heute alle nach besten wissen und
gewissen beantworten wollen außerdem
werden wir euch verraten warum putin nun
nicht mehr in der lage ist sich mit
hilfe seiner atomwaffen zu schützen
klingt spannend ist es auch also
schnallt euch an und lasst uns sofort
anfangen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bereits 1949 gelang es der sowjetunion
erstmals eine atombombe zur explosion zu
bringen das atomare zeitalter des
kommunistischen blocks hatte goll von da
an waren die sowjet bonzen geradezu
besessen davon immer mehr und immer
schrecklichere waffen in ihren
nukleararsenal anzuhäufen um euch eine
vorstellung zu geben es wird geschätzt
dass dies jetzt noch über 45.000
atomsprengköpfe hatten als ihr imperium
zusammen brach die nukleardoktrin der
union der sozialistischen
sowjetrepubliken verfolgte zwei ziele
zugleich ein politisches und ein
militärisches
[Musik]
aus politischer sicht sollte das noch
leere absender der udssr den
internationalen einfluss des landes
castiel fahren schließlich war kein
anderer staat in der lage ist mit den
vereinigten staaten aufzunehmen
andererseits war es aus militärischer
sicht die idee deshalb jetzt das regime
im fall eines krieges der möglicherweise
zu einem us atomangriff führen würde die
oberhand gewinnen sollte und so waren
sie davon überzeugt dass sie einfach nur
mehr atomwaffen als die amerikaner haben
müssten um den sieg in einem groß
angelegten konflikt erringen zu können
die dinge gerieten jedoch so außer
kontrolle dass die beiden mächte in den
60er jahren erstmals erkannten wozu das
wettrüsten geführt hatte das
gleichgewicht des schreckens die
gegenseite mit garantie der totalen
vernichtung auf englisch mitschuld
destruction abgekürzt
die doktrin also quasi die doktrin des
ersatz mit dieser erkenntnis wurde ein
paradigmenwechsel eingeleitet den beiden
streithähnen wurde klar dass ein einzig
logischerweise nie und nimmer ziehen und
zweck ihrer atomstreitmacht sein konnte
keinen block könnte jemals einen solchen
krieg gewinnen sie mussten sich also
eine andere rechtfertigung suchen und so
entstand das konzept der nuklearen
abschreckung
genau aus diesem grund unterzeichneten
die beiden mächte nur wenige jahre
später ihr erstes abkommen zur
begrenzung der fähigkeiten strategischer
waffen und ballistische flugkörper aber
das alles gehört der vergangenheit an
vor mehr als 30 jahren hörte die
sowjetunion auf zu existieren und es war
die jetzige russische föderation die im
einvernehmen aller parteien schließt
nicht alle atomwaffen des
sowjetimperiums behielt und obwohl das
erschreckende nukleararsenal seitdem
geschlüpft ist verfügt der russische bär
immer noch über ungefähr 6400
atomsprengköpfe wir die derzeit
stationierten die in reserve des
sinnlichen und die nahe zukunft
abzurüsten sprengköpfe berücksichtigen
und diese zahl
6400 atomsprengköpfe obwohl weit vom
historischen höchststand der sowjetunion
entfernt macht russland immer noch zur
größten atommacht auf dem planeten
in anbetracht dessen lautet die erste
frage die sich sicher viele von uns
stellen welche pläne hegt russland mit
all diesen waffen oder besser gefragt
wie sie in die verschiedenen szenarien
für ihren einsatz aus genau das werden
wir erst mal genauer unter die lupe
nehmen
[Musik]
russlands nukleare ambitionen
egal wie schlimm er an sich am ruder
befinden selbst im krieg gibt es
normalerweise regeln besonders wenn wir
überall national sprechen das so
zerstörerisch und selbstzerstörerisch
ist wie atomwaffen
alle ihren potenziellen einsatz zu
grunde liegenden regeln sind in einer
militärdoktrin dokumentiert und
natürlich bietet russland dabei keine
ausnahme eine militärdoktrin ist ein
komplettes in sich schlüssiges system
von prinzipien welche alle möglichen
situationen und die arten sich daraus
ergebende militärische aktion und
reaktion festlegen sie formuliert die
offiziellen grundlegenden ziele der
militärpolitik eines landes man sollte
den fehler begehen zu glauben eine
militärdoktrin seien nur propaganda nach
außen oder eine rein akademische
angelegenheit
nein in ihr stecken jahrzehntelange
erfahrung und planung und auf ihr fuß
der gesamte aufbau des militärs eine
armee lässt sich nicht einfach so
planlos aus dem boden stampfen oder über
nacht umkrempeln man muss sich aus einer
unendlichen zahl an strategien und
taktiken für die optimalen entscheiden
und die struktur ausrüstung und
ausbildung der streitkräfte müssen dann
über jahre so geformt und aufgebaut
werden dass sie den aus dieser auswahl
erwachsene aufgaben herausforderungen
gewachsen sind die militärdoktrin stellt
also die grundlage die blaupause und die
handlungsanweisungen der gesamten
streitmacht da die aktuelle russische
militärdoktrin stammt aus dem jahr 2014
aber im juni 2020 verabschiedet die die
russische regierung ein zusatz dokument
mit dem titel grundprinzipien der
staatlichen politik der russischen
föderation zur nuklearen abschreckung
dieses dokument aktualisierte diebe
drogen und umstände unter denen russland
den einsatz von atomwaffen in betracht
ziehen könnte also was meint ihr würde
es sich lohnen erst mal einen blick in
diese offiziellen russischen unterlagen
zu werfen um die frage zu beantworten
wann russland sein riesiges
erschreckendes und vernichten des
personal an atombomben einzusetzen
gedenkt ja ja wir wissen dass man putin
kein wort mehr glauben kann aber bei
einem liter doktrin ist das etwas
anderes also schauen wir doch mal was
wir darin finden können
theoretisch betrachtet moskau ab um
waffen ausschließlich als mittel zur
abschreckung
aber natürlich ist es wichtig zu wissen
was genau der begriff abschreckung in
russland wladimir putins bedeutet nun
erstens würde russland gemäß der
geltenden doktrin einen nuklearen
antritt als reaktion auf eine
vorangegangene nuklearen angriffs oder
andere arten von
massenvernichtungswaffen staaten die
gegen russland oder seine verbündeten
eingesetzt werden also 8 und cruz land
kann atome auch auf biologische oder
chemische angriff reagieren etwas
verfolgt es in letzter zeit immer mehr
öffentlich faselt zweitens werden sie
auch dann atomar reagieren wenn sie
glaubwürdige daten über einen
bevorstehenden abschuss ballistischer
raketen gegen russland oder seine
verbündeten hätten oder als reaktion auf
einen angriff mit konventionellen waffen
auf kritische regierungs oder
militärstandorte in russland drittens
und das ist sehr wichtig sieht die
russischen einsatz von abo auf den fall
vor dass auch eine rein konventioneller
konflikt die existenz des staates selbst
gefährden könnte
das klingt natürlich erstmal gruselig
und unverhältnismäßig aber im letzten
spiel die doktrin stets atomwaffen nur
gegen große militärische ziel die
flugplätze oder große marinestützpunkte
einzusetzen die mit einem einzigen
schlag für große zerstörung in den
feindlichen reihen sorgen würden es geht
also nicht um den sogenannten
strategischen einsatz was für ein ko der
euphemismus für apocalypse sondern um
den taktischen okay das sind die fälle
in denen die russische föderation den
einsatz ihrer atomsprengköpfe erwägen
würde aber sicher ist vielen von euch an
dieser stelle aufgefallen dass das alles
ja ziemlich subjektiv klingt alles
auslegungssache ist was würde also zum
beispiel passieren wenn die nato die
ukraine verteidigen oder in belarus
militärisch eingreifen würde durfte
putin eine dieser waffen einsetzen nur
weil er krieg für ihn gerade schlecht
läuft nun im prinzip gehen alle davon
aus dass atomwaffen dazu da sind
überhaupt nicht eingesetzt zu werden
aber die wahrheit ist dass die zum einen
jahr bereits eingesetzt wurden wenn auch
noch nie seitdem ist mehr als eine
atommacht auf der welt gibt
[Musik]
zum anderen gilt jedoch dass wladimir
putins größte stärke nun mal nicht die
strategie ist sondern die eigene
unberechenbarkeit seine gabe die welt
immer wieder zu überraschen und zu
überrumpeln dieser tatsache ist er sich
selbst vollkommen bewusst und deswegen
reist er diese stärke bis zum anschlag
aus der russische präsident spielt gerne
hart ball tatsächlich war eines der
ersten dinge die potentat als an die
macht kam die verabschiedung einer neuen
militärdoktrin welche die szenarien
erweiterte in denen russlands einer
atomwaffen einsetzen könnte
beispielsweise wurde als möglicher fall
das szenario eines regionalen krieges
anstelle der bisher geltenden annahme
eines globalen krieges aufgenommen
außerdem wurde das ist sehr wichtig der
inhalte es die möglichkeit eines
atomaren erstschlags ein vollständiger
paradigmenwechsel gegenüber der doktrin
der sowjetunion atomwaffen uhr als
reaktion auf einen feindlichen nuklear
angriff einzusetzen westliche
militärgeheimdienstes und analysten
deuten sogar darauf hin dass das
russische oberkommando erwägen könnte
diese waffen einzusetzen um einen
konventionellen krieg gegen die nato zu
deeskalieren sollte russland ruhen
installiert wie bitte deeskalieren mit
atomwaffen in der tat dies ist als es
karriere umzug deeskaliert strategie
bekannt ich greife zuerst an zerstöre so
viel es geht und verhandle dann wenn die
gegenseite nicht die gegenseitige
zerstörung auslösen will dahinter steckt
das kalkül einer salami taktik wie sie
putin schon oft in konventionellen krieg
eingesetzt hat es geht darum taktische
atomwaffen immer nur in einem ausmaß
einzusetzen dass knapp unter einer
proportionalen reaktionsschnelle des
gegners liegt so könnten die russen
durch geschickte dosierung nach und nach
einem gegner nach dem anderen nuclear
besiegen ohne sich selbst atombomben
einzufangen oder gar den weltuntergang
auszulösen allerdings wird von den
russen entschieden bestritten dass eine
solche strategie etwa bestandteil ihrer
doktrin wäre quasi eines geheimen
zusatzprotokoll
die fachwelt hat lange darauf bestanden
dass dieses dokument veröffentlicht wird
damit wir nicht von den amerikanern
beschuldigt würden imaginäre doktrinen
aufrechtzuerhalten wie zum beispiel
eskalation führt deeskalation das heißt
zu behaupten wir würden atomwaffen
einsetzen wollen um in einem
konventionellen konflikt den sieg zu
erringen victory sehen ehemaliger chef
des generalstabs oder stellvertretender
oberbefehlshaber der russischen
strategischen raketentruppen offiziell
würde der kreml als auch diesen schritt
nicht aktivieren das größte risiko zur
zeit besteht daher in einer verdeckten
false flag aktion über den umweg der
gegenseitigen beschuldigungen fest auch
nur beabsichtigten einsatz biologischer
oder chemischer waffen oder einer
schmutzigen atombombe die frage ist
allerdings auch hierbei soll dieses
psychospielchen wirklich dazu führen den
einsatz taktischer atomwaffen zu
legitimieren oder handelt es sich auch
wieder nur um eine art vogelscheuche mit
der der gegner mürbe gemacht werden soll
[Musik]
sicher ist auf jeden fall dass die
prominenz und bedeutung der nuklearen
abschreckung immer mehr in den
mittelpunkt der sicherheitsstrategie des
kreml gerückt ist und zwar je stärker
russland wirtschaftlich technologische
militärisch zurückgefallen ist
schließlich sind ein paar atomwaffen und
trägersysteme viel billiger als riesig
konventionelle marine oder luftflotte
mit gleicher zerstörungskraft und erst
recht nur die drohung damit ja billig
geht die welt zugrunde und bei der
invasion der ukraine konnten wir all die
enormen menge des russischen militärs
erkennen mit anderen worten gebe es
keine atomwaffen würde russland nicht
einmal als supermacht gelten und damit
dies ja niemand auch nur für eine
sekunde denkt ist ist für moskau und
insbesondere von wladimir putin von
entscheidender bedeutung dass das
atomarsenal in seinem politischen
diskurs stets sehr präsent ist das edle
danach richten die ehre die wir zuvor
gesehen haben ich bin mir sicher dass
ihr euch alle noch gut daran erinnert es
sind aussagen die einem durch mark und
bein gehen einen erschaudern lassen und
für ein permanentes gefühle unruhe im
magen sollen 27 februar 2023 putin
versetzt nukleare abschreckungskräfte in
höchste alarmbereitschaft inmitten der
sich verschärfenden spannungen um die
ukraine wobei eigentlich alle experten
erklärt haben dass diese höchste
alarmbereitschaft aus militärischer
sicht überhaupt nichts bedeutet die
atomwaffen sind ja sowieso schon die
ganzen jahre über jederzeit
einsatzbereit um die zwei schlag
fähigkeit zu gewährleisten sonst wäre ja
keine abschreckungswirkung durch einen
sofortigen zwei schlag gegeben von was
faselte da putin also wurden auch noch
ein paar andere nebelkerzen gezündet
russland startet hyperschall raketen bei
otto übungen um während der spannungen
mit der ukraine stärke zu zeigen der
psychopath putin weiß nämlich ganz genau
was diese nachrichten mit uns machen
nicht mal ernsthaft daran denkt den
weltuntergang herbeizuführen sondern
weil er weiß dass dies wirklich ein
einziger trumpf ist und internationalen
einfluss zu gewinnen seine mächtigste
waffe ist nicht die atombombe es ist
unsere angst vor der atombombe und diese
waffe es ist er immer dann geschickt ein
wenn er unsere individuelle und
kollektive psyche reden eine bestimmte
richtung manipulieren will dazu muss er
uns jedoch ständig im unklaren darüber
gelassen ob er verrückt ist oder licht
bitte verwechselt das nicht dies ist
eine vollkommen rational strategie es
geht nicht darum dass er wirklich
verrückt sein könnte sondern dass er bei
seinem gegenüber immer ein restrisiko
hinterlassen möchte er könnte ja doch
verrückt sein und die welt zerstören
wenn er in die enge getrieben würde
diesen mechanismus zu verstehen hilft
solche rhetorik ins rechte licht zu
rücken es haben sich nur um ein
klassisches psychospielchen keine echte
bedrohung deswegen passt in dieses bild
auch vollkommen dass eine sprecherin des
kreml aufbaut erklärte dass die
friedensmacht russland der allerletzte
wäre der einen atomaren erstschlag
auslösen würde außerdem wurde beteuert
dass das rote telefon der heiße draht
zwischen den atomen kommandeuren in
moskau und washington natürlich
weiterhin funktionieren würde um einen
versehentlichen weltuntergang zu
verhindern
[Musik]
grundsätzlich verbietet die in russland
gelten die militärdoktrin nämlich das
von nuklearwaffen selbst bett es in der
ukraine zu einer konventionellen kriegs
konfrontation zwischen der russischen
armee und nato truppen kommen sollte
denn tatsächlich ist es nicht russlands
nukleararsenal ansicht dass am meisten
angst macht sondern nur der gezielt
eingesetzte mangel an zurückhaltung und
besonnenheit den sein führer immer
wieder unter beweis stellt aber jetzt da
wir die situation verstehen in denen
russland seine nuklearwaffen einsetzen
könnte und warum sie auf die eine oder
andere weise in russlands rhetorik so
prominent und inflationär vorkommen
stellt sich die frage was genau sind
russlands nuklearen fähigkeiten nun
lasst uns doch mal einen blick darauf
werfen
[Musik]
das gleichgewicht des schreckens
das atom papst das gleichgewicht des
schreckens die garantie der
gegenseitigen vernichtung mio t shirt
destruction die ml die doktrin drei
ebenso ausdrucksstarke wie schreckliche
worte die den kalten krieg
kennzeichneten und die putin nun
offenbar entschlossen in unsere köpfe
zurückbringen will allerdings haben den
nuklearen arsenale der beiden großmächte
in den nächsten jahrzehnten viele
veränderungen und kürzungen erfahren vor
allem dank der vereinbarung zwischen
russland und den vereinigten staaten das
jüngste dieser abkommen heißt die eu
staat es wurde 2010 von den regierungen
von barack obama und medwedew
unterzeichnet dieses abkommen sollte im
februar 2021 auslaufen aber zwei tage
vor seinem ablauf einigten sich beiden
und putin darauf ist um fünf weitere
jahre also bis februar 2026 zu
verlängern nun warum ist das so wichtig
und worin besteht diese vereinbarung im
grunde begriff news tag die anzahl
strategischer atomwaffen jedes land
haben kann auf maximal 1550 stück mit
700 ballistischen systemen an land zu
wasser und in der luft
[Musik]
russland strategische nuklearstreit
trepte bestehen aus
interkontinentalraketen zehnten klassen
welt iphone und co sowie zwischen 60 und
70 schweren bombe es wird derzeit
angenommen dass russland über 310
interkontinentalraketen verfügt die auf
11 stützpunkte in ganz russland verteilt
sind diese raketen meisten typen markt
wird independent liegt tage trient ring
oder energie auf deutsch unabhängig
zählbare mehrfach wiedereintritt körper
können bis zu 1000 189 atomsprengköpfe
tragen obwohl derzeit nur etwa 800 davon
einsatzbereit sind russland ist momentan
dabei seine strategischen waffen zu
modernisieren und es wird erwartet dass
es bis 2022 alle seine raketen aus der
sowjetzeit ersetzt haben könnte
[Musik]
darüber hinaus wird auch angenommen dass
russland die ersten grad raketen im
einsatz haben könnte die das erste
russische ballistische hyperschall
system sind das theoretisch in der lage
ist konventionellen
raketenabwehrschildes auszuweichen diese
technologie über die auch die usa
verfügen scheint die zukunft der
nuklearen abschreckung zu sein weshalb
auch länder die nordkorea versuchen sie
zu entwickeln tatsache ist dass putin im
dezember 2020 sagte dass bis anfang 2000
22 rund 88 prozent seiner strategischen
claire streitkräfte modernisiert werden
würden allerdings haben wir auch
jahrelang propaganda über die intensive
modernisierung der russischen armee
ertragen müssen die sich nun als
übertrieben heraus stellte als auch für
sie in der ukraine die stunde der
wahrheit schlug
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und den streitkräfte sind in die sehr
weit verbreitete selbstgestellte falle
vieler macho diktatoren armeen getappt
die sowieso verhältnismäßig knappen
ressourcen ließen fast komplett in die
entwicklung beeindruckend wirken der
high tech waffen und an der langweiligen
logistik im hintergrund ohne diese
jedoch überhaupt nicht effektiv
eingesetzt werden können wird gespart
ohne ende diese budgetpolitik ist gut
für die show und natürlich auch als
werbung um diese waffen ins ausland zu
verkaufen aber in einem echten krieg
führt sie in den untergang zu malen
letzten nach dem debakel in der ukraine
auch die schlangen internationaler
häufiger russischer waffen extrem
geschrumpft sein dürfte
ein handelsembargo dass sich russland
kann man sie selbst gegen seine einstige
noch konkurrenzfähiger branche auferlegt
hat das problem der russischen armee ist
natürlich nicht nur der mangel an
ressourcen und ihre schlechte verteilung
sondern auch die grassierende und
allgegenwärtige kultur der korruption
warum auch sollte sich ein general für
das geld das für neue dichtungen und
kugellagern panzerfahrzeugen gedacht war
nicht lieber eine schicke villa auf der
krim bauen wenn es doch jeder so macht
denn all diese zustände gelten natürlich
auch für das atomarsenal dass
waffenfähiges plutonium in den
sprengköpfen degradiert mit der zeit und
muss regelmäßig ausgetauscht werden so
funktioniert die kettenreaktion nicht
das ist natürlich teuer und mühsam und
so mancher kommandeur wird sich da sich
die frage stellen ob das geld dafür
nicht irgendwo besser verwendung finden
würde
während sich die amis einen militärisch
industriellen komplex heran gezüchtet
haben müsste man das russische portal
dazu nämlich eher als militärisch
inkompetenten komplex bezeichneten es
sieht ganz danach aus dass eben diese
klassische auch nach dem untergang der
sowjetunion überwundene kombination aus
selbst lügen großmannsucht ja sager thum
inkompetenz und korruption nun dafür
verantwortlich ist dass es überhaupt zum
furchtbaren krieg in der ukraine kam
gerade zum zeitpunkt als wir dieses
video drehen berichten die unabhängigen
investigative journalisten und
geheimdienstexperten andré soldat of und
erika born über zahlreiche festnahmen in
der führungsriege des russischen
geheimdienstes fsb darunter soll sich
auch der chef der berüchtigten fünften
abteilung des
auslandsnachrichtendienstes jährige
besser da und sein stellvertreter
anatoli buch befinden ihnen wird die
eklatante fehleinschätzung des
ukrainischen widerstands zur last gelegt
und natürlich die veruntreuung von
geldmitteln die eigentlich für die
aufklärungsarbeit in der ukraine gedacht
waren das institut for the study of four
berichtet darüber hinaus dass putin nun
auf einen schlag mindestens acht
armeegeneral ausgetauscht hätte es wird
vermutet dass ihm all diese leute die
ganze zeit absichtlich
falschinformationen aufgetischt haben um
sein luftschloss vom neuen groß
russischen reich nicht platzen zu lassen
so dass sie selbst tief in seinem
hinterteil eingegraben in ruhe karriere
machen und geld scheffeln konnten tja so
ist das halt wenn man sich als system
aufbaut indem kritiker demonstrativ
vergiftet erschossen oder ins gefängnis
gesteckt werden die medien und die ganze
gesellschaft gleichgeschaltet sind
irgendwann schlagen die eigenen lügen
dann bis in die eigenen reihen und ins
eigene gehirn zurück und man glaubt
selbst an sie welch ironie des
schicksals putin wird letztlich an
derselben selbstbedienungsmentalität
scheitern mit der er selbst beim kgb und
während seiner gesamten politischen
laufbahn geld und macht angehäuft hat
wir werden uns mit dem system putin und
allen sich nun ergebenden folgen für
russland die welt und vor allem das an
ähnlichen problemen in peking in einer
ganzen reihe kräftiger videos
beschäftigen in dem wir alles ganz fein
säuberlich auseinandernehmen und wieder
zu einem schlüssigen bild zusammenfügen
werden damit ihr mit uns auch künftig
den vollen durchblick hinter die
allgemeinplätze der vielen
oberflächlichen info kanälen also
vergesst bitte nicht das abo und das
glöckchen damit ihr keines dieser videos
verpasst ich danke euch dafür aber so
wie es aussieht ist er trotz allem noch
darauf dass die angst der menschen vor
seien mehr als 6.000 atomsprengköpfen
sein größter schutzschild ist der joker
es ihm ermöglicht riskante
außenpolitische wetten einzugehen und
sich gleichzeitig schadlos zu halten
zumindest militärisch
denn es scheint dass ein derart
intensive wirtschaftskrieg und
internationale isolation nie vom kreml
in betracht gezogene bedrohungen waren
wie sonst hätte er bei kriegsausbruch 60
prozent seiner devisenreserven in
westlichen ländern oder bei vom besten
kontrollierten institutionen belassen
diese 60 prozent seiner über viele jahre
angesparte kriegskasse sind nun futsch
und genau das könnte sein größter fehler
gewesen sein aber an dieser stelle
müssen wir noch eine letzte frage
beantworten selbst wenn viele
atomsprengköpfe durch mangelnde wartung
unbrauchbar geworden sind wie viele von
ihnen sind wirklich notwendig um die
abschreckung zu gewährleisten nun laut
einer studie der technischen universität
michigan würden einem land nur 100
atomsprengköpfe ausreichen um selbst im
schlimmsten fall nukleare abschreckung
zu gewährleisten dieselbe studie kommt
übrigens zu dem schluss dass es in bezug
auf die abschreckung ausreichen würde
maximal 900 atom sprecher für weltweit
unter den heutigen nun atommächten zu
stationieren tja und wisst ihr wie viele
sprengköpfe es heute weltweit gibt nun
ungefähr 15.000 aber wie auch immer es
scheint dass putin atomwaffen immer als
russlands schutzschild nummer eins
betrachtet hat die ukraine krise hat
jedoch gezeigt dass dies ein fehler war
im vorangegangenen video haben wir euch
erklärt die westliche verbündete
versuchen die wirtschaftliche
leistungsfähigkeit russlands zu
untergraben oder gar zu zerstören und
gegen einen solchen angriff der putins
regime wirklich hinwegfegen könnte sind
atomwaffen völlig ahnungslos es gibt
auch keinen roten knopf mit dem ein mann
den weltuntergang auslösen könnte denn
auch wenn die genaue befehlskette der
russischen atomstreitkräfte nicht
vollständig bekannt ist und einfacher
sein dürfte als die der usa ist davon
auszugehen dass sowohl der
verteidigungsminister als auch der
generalstabschef einen umfassenden er
schlag verhindern könnten deswegen gibt
es ja auch den permanenten heißen draht
zwischen den russischen und
amerikanischen kommandeuren
[Musik]
ebenso können auch die regionalen
kommandeure und die offiziere an den
waffen vor ort mit ihren abschluss kurz
die befehlskette unterbrechen auch wenn
damit nur ein teil des atomschlag
verhindert würde und wenn die nadeln und
alles dafür tut nicht in direkte
kampfhandlungen in der ukraine
hineingezogen zu werden begründete sie
dies immer mit der gefahr eines
atomkriegs die wahrheit ist jedoch dass
man auch im hintergrund und in brüssel
all die zusammenhänge die wir in diesem
video dargelegt haben genau kennt die
eigentliche gefahr vor der man sich dort
fürchtet ist nicht der atomkriegs weil
die bindung der nato kräfte auf den
europäischen kriegsschauplatz welche es
ermöglichen würde im pazifik
loszuschlagen für die nato ist jeder tag
den er krieg in der ukraine ohne eigenen
kampfeinsatz an dauert ein gewinn und
für russland ein verlust denn auch wenn
die zynisch klingt nur den menschen in
der ukraine dafür einen schrecklichen
preis bezahlen müssen billiger als mit
diesen krieg hätte die nato russland nie
in die knie zwingen können man muss dies
ganz nüchtern sehen glaub mir mich
persönlich lässt das thema atom krieg
alles andere als kalt als kind bin ich
mit der permanenten angst vor dem
nuklearen armageddon midway games wie
der elfte und den letzten kindern von 7
bonn aufgewachsen die angst vor dem
atomkrieg war für uns allgegenwärtig und
jetzt heißt es die gefahr sei größer
denn je aber die wahrheit ist die
atomare abschreckung ist heutzutage
schwächer als ein wirtschafts und
finanzkrise wurde im kalten krieg
sozialisiert und demonstriert uns nun
dass er nie über die in jener ära
funktionierende denkweise hinweggekommen
ist er wollte uns wieder in diese seine
untergegangene welt in die dunklen tage
des kalten kriegs zurückversetzen aber
was soll ich sagen die zeiten haben sich
geändert und wer zu spät kommt den
bestraft bekannt nicht das leben leonie
sprechen ja es hat in den siebziger und
achtziger jahren mit seinem damals auch
aus der zeit gefallen
expressionistischen abenteuern die so
wird und über den und damit ihren
untergang vorprogrammiert wladimir
wladimirowitsch putin ist am 24 2 2022
in seine fußstapfen getreten aber jetzt
seid ihr an der reihe glaub ihr putin
wäre in der lage atomwaffen als reaktion
auf eine nato intervention bei einer
russischen invasion in einem land wie
der ukraine einzusetzen habe die
aufgrund des krieges in der ukraine
persönlich angst vor einem atomkrieg
welche strategie ist oder die nato
fahren wie sollte sie im falle des
einsatzes taktischer atomwaffen
wie immer sind wir auf eure kommentare
schon sehr gespannt hat aber bitte
verständnis dass ich zurzeit nicht so
ausführlich auf sie antworten kann ich
lese mit den meisten durch und wir
lassen uns von ihnen gerne inspirieren
aber momentan ist das schreiben neuer
video skripte wichtiger als die direkte
interaktion also ich hoffe dass euch
dieses video gefallen hat ihr vielleicht
auch etwas gelernt habt als ja gibt uns
mit einem like teils mit freunden und
vergesst nicht dass aber mit glück noch
keines unserer videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich wollen wir uns auch jederzeit
über eine spende von euch mit der uns
hält dieses projekt und weiter zu führen
denn peter link dazu findet ihr der
beschreibung unter dem video was gut und
bis bald
[Musik]
[Applaus]